- You know, to be great
I think you have to fight.
(slow music)
And I very much
think that my success
is a product of
some level of skill,
but I do think I win
because I outwork people.
I really do believe that.
I do believe that 100%.
And I'm not sure that if my
dad didn't set that example
that I'd even have the ability
to think one could
work that hard.
The fact that I've been
working 19 hours a day
everyday for the last
20 years is easy for me.
It's the only gear I knew, right?
I was poor.
I sucked shit at school.
It was the only gear I have.
You know, I think you
need to recognize
that your biggest advantage
is that you're hungrier
than your competitor.
And that if you are not
applying your one advantage,
which is your
work ethic and the hours
that you have to
put into your business,
well then you're
going to come up short.
I sit here with enormous
assumptions around all of you,
that you're just too
soft to beat me, right?
That I think that
you've had it better.
And that, that alone doesn't
allow you to beat me.
Somebody will come with the
counter cultural point of view
and be like, "Gary, that's
cool, but I don't have
"to work that hard because
I'm working smarter."
Yeah, me too, asshole.
I work hard and smart, now what?
Look, there's a
12 hour, 10 hour,
8 hour, 15 hour work day.
You can finish a lot of things
in those 18, 12, 9 hours,
or you can finish
medium amounts of things
or lightweight things.
People focus on too
many small details.
Way too many people in this
room are going to spend
the next 30,
40 years of their lives
trying to check the
boxes of the things
that they're not as good at,
and that you're going to waste
a fuckload of time and lose.
I highly recommend
for all you hustlers,
is there's a lot of you,
there's a lot of you,
that are always talking about,
"Gary, I do work hard."
And you do.
You work for 16 hours.
Some people just don't
have the attention span
or the capacity to remember.
Or like, there's a lot
of things I can't learn.
I was a very poor student
because the subject
matter bored me.
And if I was forced to
become great at understanding
the great artists of the 20th
century, I'm in big trouble.
And so, I would tell people
to bet on their strengths.
You need to bet
on your strengths
and don't give a fuck
about what you suck at.
And to put themselves
in a position to win
with their strengths
because that is absolutely
the straightest line to success.
Greatness comes from adversity
and looking the challenge
in the eye, and having
the intestinal fortitude
to step up and go after it.
(light piano music)